[Musique]
les projections de l'ap-hp que nous
avons pu consulter font craindre le pire
dans les semaines qui viennent
actuellement 1484 passion qu'ovide sont
en réanimation en ile de france dans
trois semaines il y aurait selon ses
projections 3470 personnes en
réanimation
jusqu'à une situation et compte si on la
laisse monter qui sera une citation à la
lombarde où là les familles comprendront
que les patients nous aurons sur les
brancards c'est ça c'est ça qu'on veut
éviter
nous sommes bien entendu extrêmement
attentif à ce qui se passe dans les
hôpitaux
il y a une ligne rouge absolue celle tri
des malades
notre boussole fait la protection des
français ne laisseront pas saturer les
hôpitaux ne laisserons pas les médecins
n'importe quels médecins opéraient être
en situation de devoir crier des malades
c'est impossible
la protection des français primera
toujours toujours sur toute autre
conception que nous pourrions avoir
nous allons sans doute vers un
confinement beaucoup plus larges en tous
cas un vrai confinement là où on n'était
pas trop il a véritable confinement
parce que je ne vois pas comment avec la
hausse que nous connaissons nous
pourrions passer à travers
si on fait un confinement dur il faut
une grande pédagogie dire que d'abord ça
va pas durer des mois
il aurait quelques semaines si on serre
les coudes
si on sert un peu les dents nora au bout
de ça
la lumière elle confinement dits durs
n'aurait aucun sens supplémentaire
puisqu'il sera pas respectée il ne peut
pas l'être et deux sur quoi on sait qu
en enfermant les gens chez eux on
propage davantage le virus donc je vous
propose de commettre un délit
sous les yeux des forces de l'ordre qui
ne diront rien je vous je vous propose
de vous embrasser les uns les autres
partager voilà plus on à l'instant 300
personnes rassemblées en ce moment même
sur les quais de saône pour danser sans
masque sans distance un défi vous couvre
feu dans un département qui est soumis
aux mesures de freinage renforcé que là
les gens ils soient sans masque
quasiment à tous touchés que cet abruti
leur dise de s'embrasser en plus chez
qui le façon c'est bon dans le monde de
ce soir titre le président
épidémiologistes encore failli au numéro
un il est anonyme
il consulte toutes les études au point
que parfois le président peut en évoquer
une que les experts en face de lui n'ont
même pas lu fallu au numéro 2 richard
ferrand ils cherchent chaque jour ce qui
se produit de nouveau pour ne rien
laisser passer
un jour il pourra briguer l'agrégation
d'immunologie j'ai lu ce que pouvait
dire les uns et les autres ses
courtisans qui nous expliquent qu'il est
devenu épidémiologistes ring ça va la
réalité c'est que le pari qu'il a pris
pour les françaises et les français le
29 janvier
c'est un pari perdu la palme du fayot
revient à jean michel blanquer
le président a acquis une vraie
expertise sur les sujets sanitaires
ce n'est pas un sujet accessible pour
l'intelligence comme la sienne dans ce
document officiel à la tête du centre de
formation de la police du var on demande
à une dizaine de candidats de se mettre
à la place du brigadier-chef dupond
moretti
accompagné des gardiens de la paix
darmanin et castex tous trois témoins du
vol avec violence du sac à main d'une
jeune fille une patrouille pas comme les
autres donc qui finit par attraper les
deux voleurs qui se nomme nicolas
sarkozy est incertain fillon c'est une
publicité que de nombreux lillois comme
mathilde ont eu la surprise de recevoir
dans leur boîte aux lettres un tract
pour de la vente de cannabis
bref on s'amuse bien visiblement pendant
les concours de recrutement de la bac de
toulon beaucoup moins place beauvau est
à la tête du commissariat de la ville où
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
en vue de saisir le conseil de
discipline
je suis heureux de l'hilarité l'
enthousiasme que ça déclenche chez moi
collègues parce que et les bourgs de
rire dans les cimetières
ça bien attendez en 2022 voté pour moi
et vous l'aurez tout de suite sur le
prospectus
différents types de cannabis ont proposé
un contact sur le réseau social snap
chat et une adresse ont même indiqué
afin de pouvoir retrouver le point de
deal
je vous signale un détail qui a l'air de
nous échapper je suis dans l'opposition
mais je ne demande qu'à gouverner est ce
que vous vous en aviez un patou je vous
aime bien mais a changé de ligne
politique et gardez votre humour à de
vale pour au revoir